thank you it's a pleasure to be here and
thank you for coming out on this rainy
evening although I understand it's not
such a big disincentive important to
attendance as it might be in other parts
of the country I think that one of the
things that we like to think of is that
war is some kind of aberrant behavior
that what we're going through now is
something that is not a normal part of
life but it is a distortion of life it
is something that we as human beings
don't really get involved in that much I
wish this was true but unfortunately it
isn't in the 19th century which was the
century that the the photography was
invented there were 200 Wars 200
recorded Wars even my basic math will
tell me that's an average of two a year
and because of that because war is one
of the perpetual human activities
photography has always covered it as one
of its great themes the earliest war
that was covered photographically was
the crimean war by a man called Roger
Fenton in the war itself lasted between
1854 and 1856 this was literally just a
few years after the medium had been
invented and he started a tradition of
war photography and more related
photography that went through Mathew
Brady and his photographers during the
American Civil War continued right away
through the first world war and is with
us today today three out of the ten
photographers in the book are in the
Middle East
two of them are embedded with combat
groups one with an airborne group which
will probably go behind enemy lines and
when I was doing this but when people
knew when I spoke to friends and
and and colleagues about the book I was
doing I think the question which came up
most was why on earth would people do
this why would people put their lives at
risk constantly and I think the answer
exists on many levels as Mimi mentioned
in the introduction I covered two wars
both civil wars I hated them I hated
being there I didn't want to be there I
had a sore throat from the moment I got
there to the moment I left I did not
want to be a war photographer but I
covered them because I was a journalist
and these were important stories and it
gave me a very heightened respect for
those people who can do this year after
year after year we have two
photographers in the book one Patrick
Chapelle a Frenchman the first war that
he covered was the 67 war in Israel he
is back in Israel as we speak covering
the war from the Israeli side he has
been at combat shooting combat for
30-plus years Jim nachtweh the gentleman
who is at the very front of his picture
and who you may have seen in the movie
war photographer the first conflict he
covered was in 1981 he has been in
constant combat pretty much constant for
over 20 years these men and women have
more combat experience than any of the
soldiers they will be working beside
they have more current with some of them
have more combat experience than the
generals who are running this war so why
is it why is it that they will complete
keep on going back I think that the
reason is different for each one of them
I think it is often a multi-layered
reason and I think that one of the
things we must never forget never lose
sight of is that war is a spectacle
which is dramatic war is a an
environment where you can get quote
unquote
pictures one of my favorite military
historians a guy called John Glenn gray
in the Warriors said war is a spectacle
as something to see ought never to be
underestimated
there is in all of us what the Bible
calls the lust of the eye and certainly
this is echoed by some of the
photographers in the book Patrick
Chevelle talking about the six-day war
in Israel says the heavier the fighting
got the more I could feel even why I had
fingers everything came into place my
eyes could see what I needed them to see
I could hear and I needed to hear fast I
could run fast I could walk fast I
wasn't tired hungry or thirsty I felt so
alive but there is also the other side
of it which Catherine Laroy expresses
she was a she is a French photographer
who spent a huge amount of time in
Vietnam from a very young age and what
she said is sometimes there's so much
fear that you reach a crescendo of
terror I was so frightened sometimes so
frightened but when it was all over and
I was alive and unhurt the release of
fear gives you a rush a high of just
being alive you're alive like you've
never felt alive before it's not
something that's pleasurable in a
sensual sense its present pleasurable in
this sense of sheer animal survival it's
your primary brain your reptilian brain
it's very low and very primal this is
certainly one of the reasons but of the
ten photographers there are in the book
I think there's a much stronger and
overriding reason I think we all of us
like to feel that the work that we do is
important and we feel it some days we
feel it
other days sometimes we think it's
futile for these people they have I
think complete conviction that the work
they're doing is important whatever
level it's accepted on as was mentioned
in the introduction some of them really
do think that by showing the world the
reality of war that they can help change
events that may be even in perceptively
even by a little bit you can shift
humanity's focus and there are those who
really don't think this is going to
happen that war is something which has
been with us for so long that is
programmed into us so deeply it will
never change but the importance of being
witness means that revisionist
historians in the future and
propagandists in the future will never
be able to say that event didn't happen
because there will be irrefutable
evidence that it did and in fact
actually one of the photographers in
here young man could run envied the work
that he did in Bosnia and the former
Yugoslavia is used by the international
war crimes tribunal at the hague as a
part of the evidence said bringing
against several of the people they've
leveled war criminal charges and so
there are very tangible ways in which we
know that this that this is important we
live in an age where war has become very
much more dangerous to to cover the kind
of war that we're talking about now the
kind of war were involved in now it's
very much more along the lines although
not completely of a traditional kind of
conflict one army against another army
one group against another group most of
the wars that these guys cover are not
that organized or not that they're more
chaotic and the more chaotic the war is
and the more chaotic it becomes the more
dangerous it is to cover I know that
when we were in Salvador there is no
safe zone when you are in this kind of a
war there is no safe zone in first world
war
or you could be at the front line and
literally 20 miles away you could go and
have a very nice dinner in a very nice
restaurant that doesn't happen in the
civil war if you look at the events that
have happened recently in in Israel war
is in a cafeteria in a university war is
on a bus if you look at the events that
have happened in our country war is in
an office building and one of the things
that has happened is that civilians as a
component of war have become much more
important to the war mongers
particularly in the internecine kind of
strife where you get such things as the
infamous ethnic cleansing and this
presents extra challenges to the
photographer and one of the things I
think that if you look at the book you
know this is a book of war photographs
but you will find not that many pictures
of action many more pictures of the
result of the action rather than the
action itself I want to just go through
now some of the images and some of the
words that the photographers shared with
me in the book a friend of mine who I'm
staying with in Portland said you know
Peter this is the weirdest photo book
that I've ever seen because in fact the
stories are more important than the
pictures and that's the actual truth
this is the stories in this book are
much more important than the pictures
because what they do is they give us I
hope a window into the world of the war
photographer and what is their
motivation and and how they operate what
the ethical and moral conflicts that
they they go through this is the work of
Patrick chevelle he's the photographer
who I said was the first photographer to
to to cover the even covered the 67 war
and he's been he's still covering and he
is a man of strong opinions as they all
are
and he found that the war in the former
Yugoslavia was the most difficult world
that he had to cover the fighting was
very sporadic and spread out he was we
were freezing there was no electricity
and the guys had an attitude I didn't
like either side I didn't like the Serbs
I didn't like the Bosnians and I hated
the Croats I didn't like the mission of
the French army I think we were lying to
everyone
everybody was lying I hated that place
that was probably the most not really
hard but miserable war somebody asked me
today in an interview whether these were
dispassionate and objective
reporters and the answer is no none of
them are objective and dispassionate
photography is a medium of emotion the
reason the photographs appealed to us is
not because they necessarily appeal to
our intellect they cannot argue the case
for or against a war but what they can
do is they can attach themselves to our
emotions and that is where their power
lies and as you're dealing with a very
emotional medium it's very hard to be
dispassionate because there isn't a lot
of passion in these four in these
photographs Philip Jones Griffiths is a
wonderful photographer who did for me
what is the the best book that ever came
out of the Vietnam War it's called
Vietnam incorporated and it has just
been reprinted and it is selling like
crazy and he shows us here one of the
things which is a constant feature of
battle it's the surreal situations that
occur it is the surreal nature of war
because war is so far detached from
everyday and what we like to think of as
normal behavior and here as he says
we're actually under fire there's no
question that it was real the enemy was
less than a hundred yards away and they
were shooting the guy in the chair is
giving covering fire and he's sitting as
casually as you can please as if he's
off on a holiday somewhere
there's a doll under the floor on the
floor under his chair that's war it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable there's
an interesting story that is attached to
this picture the guy lying down on the
stretcher is a Vietcong fighter and if
you look to the bottom of the frame you
will see on his stomach is a an enamel
ball which he probably borrowed from
some peasant farmer and he's taped it
around his stomach
the reason that he's taped it around his
stomach is that his intestines are in it
he was wounded very badly about three
days before this happened and he fought
on the GIS who are attending to him here
were going to give him water because
stomach wounds one of the effects of
stomach means that you get incredibly
thirsty and their Vietnamese
interpreters said he's fair calm give
him paddy water the paddy is that body
of water to the side which is brown
filthy and one of the soldiers said any
man who can fight like this for three
days deserves my canteen of water to me
this picture is one of the most moving
in the book and it goes back to what I
was saying before about how many of the
pictures and nothing to do with the
action of war this shows an American
soldier and a Vietnamese child and I
think when you look at the faces of both
of them you will see that they are in
fact both victims of war the soldier has
the look in his eyes of somebody who has
seen too much too soon and it is a look
which is consistent from every single
war that you would ever see that's being
photographed
Ronn Aviv as you can see was born in
1969 so from my point of view he's you
know barely out of diapers but he has
had a huge amount of experience he's
been put on the Serbian death list he
probably still is on the Serbian death
list
he was arrested he's been beaten he's
been through a huge amount of toil and
turmoil to produce the work that he's
produced and when you look and you see
the the caption about these boys they
look about 15 or 16 which was pretty
much consistent with the reports that we
were hearing about lots of young kids on
the Taliban front line what happened
after I left them I'm not sure the one
soldier is pointing an RPG at them which
had he used it would have killed us all
but they're Afghans they have a whole
other concept of brutality one of the
things that everyone asks these guys
whenever these guys are doing any kind
of a talk or any kind of lecture one of
the things these they're always asked is
did you ever help do these people ever
help to pee of the people that they can
see in front of their cameras and the
answer is if it's possible if it doesn't
get them killed and if they're going to
do any good in this particular instance
using some very basic Afghani language
which he had picked up while he was
there he managed to persuade the guys
who are holding the weapons to let these
two children go he said whether of
course they didn't execute them a half
an hour after he left he didn't know but
at least he managed to get them to give
them some freedom for however brief a
period of time it was this is a
paramilitary leader whose name I will
not even attempt to to pronounce he had
a paramilitary unit called the tiger
unit and this little thing that he's
holding up is a real tiger cub
which they are just quote-unquote
liberated from the Sarajevo zoo and they
were going to use as their mascot the
the Serb leader himself was later
assassinated by rival forces one of the
things that war photographers I mean all
photographers to a certain extent but
definitely war photographers have to
really deal with is being intrusive by
intruding upon the most desperate
moments him often in people's lives one
of the photographer's is Don McCullen in
this book puts it very succinctly for me
in as much as he had the misfortune to
one day find his wife dead in bed she
died of natural causes she was dead in
bed and he said that if somebody had
come running up his stairs at that
particular time and started taking
photographs he would have kicked them
straight back down those stairs and yet
he said this is what I do I am the
person running up the stairs into these
most intimate moments and this is the
picture of a a commander in the Northern
Alliance forces they were coming across
a hill and they came under sniper fire
and the commander got hit and he was
laying there dying and the photographer
said I realized as I was shooting the
pictures that the last image that this
man would see which was me and my camera
and although the photographer was doing
his job it's not an easy job to do under
those circumstances one of the
extraordinary things about warfare
because it is something that has been
going on for so long often it it looks
like it has been going on for so long
and these if you took away the
Kalashnikov that this guy is holding in
his hands this picture could have been
taken any time in the last probably four
or five hundred years in in Afghanistan
one of the things I think that impressed
all of the photographers who went there
that the Afghani czar a warrior nation
they really are Catharine Laroy
is a five-foot French woman and every
foot of her is as tough as you could
possibly imagine when she went to
Vietnam when she was 21
and she stayed there I believe it was
for three years and when she went to
cover the Battle of Wei Battle of her
weight of way was the bloodiest battle
of the and also the most I believe the
most prolonged battle of the Vietnam War
they got captured she and the French
writer she was rid got captured by the
North Vietnamese army
she says we'd only gone about 150 meters
with our young guide when suddenly we
were surrounded by North Vietnamese
soldiers my camera was taken off my
shoulders and my hands were tied behind
my back
despite France where it was the writers
saying don't tie up the woman you
shouldn't tie up a woman this is a the
French are very careful about telling of
women the NVA were everywhere and I was
shaking I was really scared but of
course she stuck continues shooting and
as a result of which she brought back
through her captivity which was only for
five hours and believe me if I'd
captured Catherine Laroy it would have
probably been about two hours but she
brought back some of the only
photographs we have of regular North
Vietnamese soldiers as opposed to Viet
Cong this is one of them this is one of
the North Vietnamese snipers working in
Hawaii and this is probably his targets
and maybe his victims one of the things
that Catherine says which i think is
absolutely true is that she said many of
us in Vietnam were against the war but
few of us were against the soldiers
fighting the war she said we were
sharing the same miserable conditions
they were they were our brothers and how
could we hate them
Don McCullen is probably one of the
finest war photographers who's ever
lived and certainly one of the finest
war photographers from the last half of
the 20th century he now only photographs
landscapes he says that the reason he
photographs landscapes is because there
are no bills to pay and he's not talking
about utility bills or American Express
bills he's talking about emotional bills
about psychological bills and he talks
about one things I think that people
don't understand is that firefights are
usually very brief
they're usually 15-20 minutes half an
hour an hour they're not usually
measured in days are usually measured in
hours at the maximum but where he was
nearly two weeks of continuous and
bloody battle and as he says here I
walked away from that battle totally
totally insane I slept on the floor on
tables near dead bodies one day I went
out of a building there was a dead North
Vietnamese soldier another day I'd gone
out there was another dead soldier being
run over by a tank so he looks like a
Persian carpet one day I found a naked
Vietnamese foot and I thought this is
like being in hell to me this is I think
one of the most moving pictures in the
entire book one thing a lot of people
don't understand is that famine is a
weapon of war one of the easiest ways to
conquer your adversary is to really kill
the farmers kill the cattle destroy the
crops poison the grain and you will
produce a situation where you have a
severely weakened enemy and this I think
what Don says here is encapsulate a lot
of the conflicts and a lot of the
emotional distress that war
photographers had to live with I took a
photograph of an albino boy there I
photographed him and just walked away
but he followed me and he held onto my
hand every time I'm in the darkroom and
that image comes up through the
developer it's a haunting experience
I rarely print that picture that boy are
many people in those images did not
survive
and you say how can I justify this but
how can I not do it you're trapped in a
no-win situation you want to go there
and bring attention to what's happening
so that others might be saved but you're
not going to save that boy so whatever
your achievements are however small or
large they may be you still walk away
with the slight crime on your hands that
picture in this one we're taken in
Biafra in 1968 it was a particularly
nasty civil war the Igbo tribe in in
Nigeria wanted to secede from the
country mostly because they were sitting
on all of the oil reserves of the
country you would be surprised how many
wars we fight which are over oil it was
a it was a war that they couldn't win
and didn't win and in this particular
instance this is one of the Beaufighters
a captain called captain Peter Asher
Davy and he is talking to a corpse which
is one of his soldiers who've just been
killed
and he's telling that corpse that he is
a son of BI ephra and that the Biafran
people honor him that the buyer from
people are proud of him he should be
proud of fighting and Don said of course
he was insane he was totally insane at
that point because of the stress of war
that he been through he was insane and
many of the photographers themselves get
to the point where they too are insane
where they too had breakdowns where they
have to be pulled out of the field where
they had to be sent back for rest and
recuperation there was an interesting
study that was done by the University of
Toronto recently and they studied the
war correspondents of five major news
organizations these weren't just
photographers things were videographers
reporters whatever they found that the
incidence of stress-related illnesses
amongst them was higher than that of the
police or the firefighters and at about
the same level as combat fighters which
to me is not surprising you are in the
same position you're in this
same situation you are under the same
stress I have a history with this
photograph in 1970 I was an assistant in
London to a photographer and Don
McCullen got wounded out of in the book
out of the book six of the photographers
that are in the book have been wounded
one almost mortally and in fact out of
the three women photographers are also
in the book
two of them were among the wounded in
this particular instance in Cambodia Don
was wounded and he'd been standing
behind a jeep they shell landed in front
of the Jeep it hit this guy with full
force but some of the shrapnel came
under the Jeep and hit done in the groin
they evacuated him in this as you can
see just an ordinary truck and he said
he was in such pain that the only thing
he could think of was to keep shooting
pictures and he realizes he's shooting
pictures that the guy he's taking
photographs of could have easily been
him had they been in the reverse
positions when they evacuated Don to a
hospital in Tokyo the film was sent back
to London and the photographer I worked
with was one of the best black-and-white
printers in London and I was with him
when this picture was printed I was the
first person to see this picture come up
through the developer here again we're
with Susan my sailors one of the three
women in the book and we come across
another surreal situation it's in the
Civil War in Nicaragua it's towards the
end of the Civil War and as she says
here the guerrilla with the clarinet
ikonn into army headquarters and found
the army bands instruments and decided
that it was almost over and he was right
it's the turning point and so he's sort
of celebrating
this is not a surreal situation but a
devastating situation
these are Marinol nuns who were captured
by right-wing paramilitary death squads
raped tortured and killed and buried in
a shallow grave Salvador was a very very
very nasty war it had levels of cruelty
in it that you would scarcely believe
and one of the ways that we talked about
how the work that these photographers do
can help is that the photographs that
she took on that day are being used by
the families of the murdered nuns in
civil lawsuits that they have brought
against the then Minister of Defense and
the then head of the National Guard
because these paramilitary the the guys
who did this were in the Civil Guard and
they had it was they're sort of you know
that what they did in their spare time I
think that the children are always the
the most heart-rending
victims of war Christopher Morris who is
a contract photographer for time who did
a huge amount of work in Sarajevo says
of this child there was something about
the boy that reminded me of myself I
looked at him and I saw myself as a
child we very similar features it was if
I become one with the boy in the photo
and then I wept I wept over all the
death I had seen and one of the things
that chris says is that he has never
gone through when you shooting for a
free magazine at least it used to be
that now that there's digital cameras
it's slightly different but what you
used to do was you would ship all the
film and they would process it and they
would use the ones that they wanted and
then they would send those back that
they all of the film back and it was
called the returns he said he's never
been able to go through the return
that he got from this particular period
of time Chris was one of the people who
had a nervous breakdown while he was in
Sarajevo this picture is of children who
had been tobogganing in Sarajevo when a
shell came in and killed them all he
went to the morgue where they were and
photographed them and while he was there
a man and an older man probably the
father and grandfather of some of these
children came in to identify the bodies
he had heard on the BBC on the BBC World
Service which is something that all of
the photographer's listen to because in
some ways even now it's the most
unbiased reporting that you can get one
of the things that's interesting about
war situations is you often know much
much less about what's going on because
of the chaos and everything that's going
on around you you know less than people
outside in the outside world and he had
heard the same day that he shot these
photographs Clinton say that there was
no humanitarian crisis in Sarajevo that
the people weren't starving and after
he'd seen these these children he went
to the phone and screamed down the phone
at his office at the time office
demanding that they contact the White
House demanding that he be put through
to the highest level if the government
that they were putting through because
this was an outrage and and he just lost
it he completely lost it and time just
pulled him out of there and brought him
back and this happens to most
photographers many photographers my
admiration for them is that you can go
through this and that you can then go
back and do it again it is a level of
commitment which i think is quite
extraordinary Jim not way is probably
the most famous war photographer alive
today
as I said he's been photographing since
1981 and he happened to be in his
apartment on September the 11th and his
which is in itself a rare thing because
he's nearly always on the road he was in
his apartment and it's just a few blocks
from the World Trade Center he saw the
first plane hit and rushed down with his
cameras to start working he says here as
I was photographing I heard what sounded
like a huge waterfall in the sky I
looked up and saw the second tower
falling straight down on me it was an
image from a nightmare it was unreal in
a fraction of a second I recognized what
an incredible sight it was that it
actually looked very beautiful as well
as terrifying that it would make a
brilliant photograph and that if I took
even a moment to raise my camera I would
not survive and in fact the only reason
that Jim did survive that day was
because he's a very very experienced
combat photographer he ran from where he
was where the tower was coming down into
the lobby of a hotel in the Millennium
Hotel and he realized when he got in
there because of his combat experience
that as that tower would come down the
whole Lobby would be taken out and he
looked across the lobby and he saw an
elevator with this doors open he ran to
the elevator pulling a construction
worker who happened to be in the lobby
with him they got into the elevator he
gave them just enough protection that
when the tower came down and completely
obliterated the lobby they weren't
killed
now these decisions are made in
microseconds fractions of a second and
because of his experience he managed to
save himself and the life of the
construction worker one of the things
that interested him about this picture
and one of the reasons he thought it was
a an important picture is it's the two
it's two poles it's a bedroom where life
starts and it's a gunman where life ends
mostar was a very very tough battle and
i don't know if you can see but if you
see where those little dots all the way
around on the on the pavement there
those are share are bullet casings which
shows you just how many rounds have been
fired that particular day also one of
the things that now photographers have
become have to become very aware of very
sensitive to is the fact that
particularly in situations where you
have these groups of warlords as opposed
to military authorities that are
somewhat more structured and i have to
really be to a certain extent more
responsible photographers are being used
as propaganda they're trying to be
manipulated to produce work which the
side that they're working with can use
to influence either the enemy or public
opinion or whatever and this was
certainly the case here the paramilitary
units here had their own PR guy who was
a serbian american from chicago and he
arranged for the gym took to go to this
particular location it was it was done
in a very efficient way when we were in
salvador the hotel each battle each war
has it so impressed so tell where
everyone stays and they stay there
because it's safer than staying anywhere
else and in el salvador in san salvador
it was the camino al an outside the
camino al was a bus shelter where the
buses stopped
and even then and this is in the early
eighties the rebels used to leave press
releases in the bus shelter because they
knew that the press stayed in that hotel
and they would pick them up people have
become incredibly sophisticated about
the media and it's placed yet another
level of challenge upon these guys
thankee stibor when I asked Maggie if
she would like to be in this book about
combat photographer she said I'm not a
combat photographer and I said well
where didn't you cover the Haiti
elections in 1987 and she said yes I
said didn't you nearly have your head
macheted off by one of the thugs that
were trying to prevent the election she
said yes I said didn't you photograph a
lot of firefights and a lot of corpses
she said yes I said well from my point
of view that makes you a combat
photographer and I think it also
reinforces the point that nowadays the
battle is everywhere war is everywhere
we've just you know we have midterm
elections and they're fairly orderly and
everyone comes and leave vote or they
don't vote but in Haiti and the
elections in 1987 there were groups of
people going around literally shooting
up voter lines and the courage that the
people who actually went out to vote had
was quite extraordinary and I think that
this is interesting because again it
goes back what she says here goes back
to the idea of intrusion in those days
there were so many corpses that you've
got not jaded exactly but to the point
that you couldn't photograph everybody
and yet the Haitian people wanted you to
do just that I said to our Haitian
friend you know I just can't do it
anymore I can't photograph all these
bodies I feel like a vulture she put her
hands on our ample hips and said Maggie
you have to because every single body
that you photograph was a living person
and they all have to count for something
one of the things that again is
something that these photographers have
to look at is that you're making what
are aesthetic decisions over gruesome
sights over how do you take a beautiful
photograph how do you take a well
compose further everyone the thing is
that these are all very very good
photographers and two very good
photographers
it is almost an instant it comes like
second nature you frame you compose
instinctively this is a remarkable
picture I think it is the body of
somebody had been shot and the people
who were trying to prevent the elections
would take people they had executed put
the bodies in places where a lot of
people would see them as a sort of
disincentive for other people to go out
and vote and he happened to be in a blue
part of a house which was painted blue
and that he became this strange blue
object loren van der stalk again a
younger photographer will never be a war
photographer again he's been wounded
twice the last time he was wounded he
was targeted by an Israeli armored
sniper and he was shot through the
kneecap as a result of which he is semi
paralyzed and will never be able to go
back into a battle zone because one of
the things you all have to be when
you're in these kind of environments is
you have to be super fit you absolutely
have to be able to move quickly you have
to be able to run you have to be able to
hide and he can't do that
he was in Chechnya and he said that he
was totally impressed by the Chechens
they're an amazing people they're a
strong community with a strong culture
and a strong identity and they know how
to survive I have learned a lot from the
Chechens there are beautiful people I'm
not speaking about the individuals
because there are beautiful individuals
everywhere I'm speaking about the group
the attitude of the Chechens is why I
went there
I'm just in love with these people he
also when he was in Moscow was told by
an old man a very old man living him in
Moscow and the conditions are under
which civilians were living in Moscow
was absolutely appalling and the old man
saw he had a camera
to him and said you know we can we
understand and can accept that these
people hate us we understand that they
will shoot us down like rabbits but the
real tragedy would be if it goes
unrecorded if nobody knows about it
because if that happens then he will go
on forever there will be no end to this
and it was at a point in his career
where he was feeling that this was
something he shouldn't be doing he
didn't want to do but this old man who
probably did dies shortly afterwards
gave him the courage and the strength to
carry on this was taken from the first
time that he was ever in combat
he's a Belgian and he drove to Romania
as a very young man and decided he
wanted to shoot to get into
photographing action one of the things
that happens and one of the reasons Jim
not plays alive is that it's very much
like with soldiers the first people to
die in battle are always the least
experienced soldiers the first
photographers the divine battle are
waste of the least experienced
photographers and he was waiting outside
the Romanian border when some other
journalists came up and he was in his
car and they said was he going into into
Romania and he said yes he was going and
they said we get a lift with you they
said fine and they drove into Romania
and the first thing he did was he drove
through an intersection where there was
a firefight going on and he drove
straight away through it
that car was entirely shot up and one of
the journalists that he was giving a
lift to was seriously wounded
unfortunately survived and Lauren said
at that night he said you know if it's
gonna be like this every day I don't
think I'm going to be able to do this
job another thing that I people don't
really think about when they think when
you pick up your newspaper or your Time
magazine or wherever it is you see this
kind of photography and you look at
anything yeah these are brave guys you
know they
there you know dodging bullets at
dodging shells they're dodging landmines
I think one of the things we don't think
about is what it actually takes to
survive outside of that in Chechnya when
he was working there
there was no hotels no restaurants no
taxis no running water no electricity
very few food outlets and if you imagine
what it is you would pack in a suitcase
to go to say Florida for a week and then
think what is it that you would pack to
go to Chechnya for a month or two months
because it's so hard to get in there and
you have to go through two sets of
Russian lines to get in there that it'll
take you so long to get in there you're
gonna be there for two three months what
do you take to be able to survive the
last thing you pack is clothes they're
the least of it you don't care whether
you've got a clean shirt or clean
underwear you would pack a shortwave
radio you would pack a water
purification unit you would pack some
kind of sustainable food that would not
perish these are the kind of things that
a war photographer packs when they go
away and this is a picture of a Chechen
fighter in Chechnya at that time and
probably still in Grozny they're
probably still nowadays a lot of people
who lived in the basements of their
houses because there were no houses
above there or the houses that were
above they were not inhabitable and this
woman came in with this fighter from the
outside into Grozny and she is preparing
her husband to go to work
she's putting together the kit that he
requires all of the equipment that he
needs to send him off to work and she
has chosen to stay with him to the very
end and I always leave this image up
because to me this is you know this is a
representative of the ultimate that war
photographers give us
it's taken from the last roll of film
shot by bill bigot and bill had a lot of
combat experience he had been in a lot
of places he'd done a lot of work in the
Middle East and he was under the second
tower of the World Trade Center when it
collapsed when they found his body they
found his cameras beside his body and
remarkably the film although as you can
see is damaged with light leakage were
still usable in fact actually
interestingly enough the digital camera
that he was using you would have never
known that a hundred and two story
building and fallen upon him he was not
necessarily the greatest war
photographer that's ever lived but he
was a dedicated and committed man and he
perished during the job that he loved he
called his wife about 20 minutes before
this happened and told her he was coming
out he was on his way back his now Widow
said of him that he was an honorary guy
he died doing what he loved to do and he
took two of the biggest buildings in the
world to finish him we're dealing here
with obviously incredibly serious topics
incredibly weighty things but I think
one of the things that one of the things
that is interesting to me is that it's
not without its light side and since I
don't want you all to go out and jump
out of the window at this particular
point
maybe we'll discuss some of the light
side there one of the things that
happens with with war photographers is
they're incredibly tight bunch of people
run of Yves said and there's no way of
proving this but it's probably almost
accurate that he felt that 80% that the
photographs out of war zones that you
see I've taken by a group of probably 20
five to 30 people there people who see
each other in all of these different
locations they're very tightly bonded
Jim Knightley described it as
friendships forged in fire and they tell
the most wonderful stories these stories
that in the book and the reason my
friend was absolutely right when he said
the stories are more important I really
I mean compelling moving and were so
funny one of the things that happened to
Philip Jones Griffiths he's talking
about traveling around Vietnam Evette
getting around Vietnam was very easy if
you had your military accreditation
which in itself was very easy to get at
the beginning of the war at least you
could just hop on a on a helicopter or a
transport plane he had a theory that
that military pilots had some kind of
frequent flyer mileage system because
the number of times he once flew back to
Hanoi Hanoi to Saigon in a huge
transport plane which only had the crew
and him on board and the only reason
they were coming was to bring him back
to Saigon but he talked about going
around South Vietnam he said I found
traveling around South Bay I'm actually
very easy although there were rules that
you had to follow in games you had to
play once I wanted to get to a certain
location than this pio press information
officer let me to a helicopter and said
to the pilot take mr. Griffis to Hanoi
what annoy the pilot says take him to
Hanoi the PIO says and the guy takes off
his helmet and which says repeat that
sir i annoy the poet Pio Boggs then oh
no no no I'm sorry
ho-yang which is it's rather beautiful
little town on the coast what would have
happened had a US military helicopter
with a US photographer in it done if it
had landed in Hanoi I leave to your
imagination one of the other things and
this is Patrick Ravel Patrick chevelle
he's almost like your joke Frenchman
Patrick Chevelle is so French that you
wouldn't believe it if you met him and
he said on one of my trips to Chechnya I
stayed for two weeks in the same house
as this beautiful American woman
photographer did you see the film Out of
Africa when Robert Redford washes Meryl
Streep's hair in the bush and just after
that they had dinner under the stars and
she puts his hand on her shoulder shrugs
his head and they made love
well this photographer had long red hair
and she got so much stuff in it that I
said do you want me to wash your hair
she was a bit surprised by my offer but
she said okay I think she was amused so
I took this water jug and washed her
hair then we had dinner which meant we
had a little bit of cheese and crackers
and then well I don't think she saw the
film she probably still wonders why I
washed her hair I suppose I should send
her the tape the other thing which I
loved the other story which I love is
that as I told you catherine Laroy is
this tiny French woman I mean she is
timing and as a result of which she
doesn't have a lot of physical strength
and so when she would go into battle
instead of taking C rations which were
heavy she had found in in Saigon
remember
Vietnam was Indochina which was a French
province
she found a store which sold six packs
of Beaujolais wine so she would take a
six-pack of Beaujolais wine into battle
with her in her poncho and she would
share it with the guys she said she
never had any problem getting guys to
work with her so anyway these are the
these are the men and women these are
the men and women who I admire enormous
Lee I think that the job that they do is
incredibly important to us one of the
things that I really feel is that
democracy the information is the fuel
the drives democracy and without
accurate information you and I as
citizens of democracy cannot make
accurate decisions and that particularly
at a time in the world experiencing now
we need as much
information about the reality of war as
we can possibly get I think that there
is a romanticism to war which doesn't
exist at all even the most justified war
the one that you can say without any
doubt this was a war worth fighting is a
tragedy it's always a tragedy
there are children alive today who are
going to be dead in a day's time ten
days time there are young American men
and women who are alive today who are
going to be dead in the same period of
time and that is the reality of war
somebody asked me today you know should
you show dead bodies dead bodies have
been in every single war there has never
been a war without their bodies that is
a reality of war and I think that we owe
a huge debt as a society as a nation to
these people whose commitment is so
strong that they are prepared to risk
their lives they are prepared to go out
time and time again and bring back or
send back the information that we so
desperately need and thank you very much
indeed for your attention
now two things I'm gonna ask you okay
first I'm gonna repeat please when you
ask the question you want to ask a
question wait until the microphone gets
to you the second is in the same way
that people leave their hearts in San
Francisco
I left my hearing at a rock concert in
1983 which I covered without the benefit
of hearing protection if I were if I
could have pay if there any young
photographers in this audience my one
piece of advice to you is if you're
going to a rock concert wear hearing
protection I reserved a concert was
sitting in the police and that was it I
haven't heard properly since then so
please articulate your questions very
carefully because I need to hear them
very clearly become more media savvy I
wonder if any of them have started to
specifically target journalists
photographers people like that yeah
absolutely they have and in fact there
is a certain amount of evidence which
you obviously can't quantify that the
Israeli Defense Forces do target
journalists that is how Lauren van der
stadt got shot one of the things that
Patrick Chevelle talks about alluring
and he was in the sea he was in Israel
at the same time or on the west bank the
same time the Lauren got shot he said
that the the way you can tell is if
there's a lot of firing around and you
know they just scared draftees who are
just shooting off their weapons then you
were probably just unlucky if there's
just one shot and he gets you you were
probably targeted but targeting is not a
new thing it's something that has
happened a lot there was a very famous
Australian War cameraman
who was in I think was in Cambodia in
the middle of an unbelievable firefight
we're in all sorts of hell was coming
down on them and one of his colleagues
said Neil we gotta get out of here and
he said I can't I can't move somebody's
shooting at me
and what he meant was was somebody was
targeting him that he was being targeted
and he could not move because he knew
that if he moved he would get killed
over there I was wondering what you
thought the effect of having the
photographer's embedded with the
American troops was going to be their
work well it'll be interesting to see I
mean it's not a new system it's a system
that was in place in the Second World
War and seem to work pretty well in the
Second World War the interesting thing I
think about it is is that I personally
believe that the Pentagon realize that
they over controlled media access during
the first Gulf War and as a result of
which they didn't get the kind of press
that they would like because it was so
tightly controlled and they realized
they need the American people to see
what's happening they need the American
people to know what's happening and they
are claiming and God blessed my let's
hope that this is true that no
photographer will be censored that what
there will be is blackout periods and
which is absolutely perfectly you know
nobody could disagree with a blackout
period particularly the photographers
because one of the things you have to
remember is any intelligence that the
enemy gets from a photograph is going to
affect a photographer with the soldiers
as much as the soldiers themselves so
just from the mere point of view of
survival they don't want that to happen
but if that is true then this will be a
major improvement in the relations
between the press and the Pentagon and I
think it's about time you know the
Vietnam War was a long while ago and so
much of this is based upon the memories
of
this gentleman he um after covering
situations like this how many
photographers can go back and just cover
ordinary routine assignments it's an
interesting question what when I did the
interview with Chris Morris I did it in
Washington because he was now one of the
rotating photographers that cover the
White House with Time magazine and he
said that he had given up being a combat
photographer he said the reason that
he'd given up being a combat
photographer because he had a
three-year-old daughter and the way he
put it was he said you know when I'm 70
years old am I going to sit there and
look back at a picture of my daughter at
3:00 or a Taliban fighter and he said to
me my problem my priorities have changed
about 3-4 months later he was in
Afghanistan you know he was in
Afghanistan doing features and he was
about after the action but it is very
compelling one of the things that
happens is and one things I found
personally were my own experiences
combat is one of those human experiences
that unless you've been in it you can
never thoroughly understand what it is
and what happens is this causes an
isolation between you and people who
haven't been in it it's in it's totally
impossible I couldn't if you I don't
whether you've been in combat or not but
if you haven't
oh my little thing right now but anyway
we finished it so that's fine if you
haven't I can't tell you what it's like
to be in combat because it's just an
unknowable experience and unexpressable
experience I think this is also
something that does add to
post-traumatic stress syndrome it's a
feeling of isolation that you know both
photographers and combat veterans feel
the sense of isolation when you come
back to to the world after you've been
in somewhere like Salvador or something
like Church
wherever it is to be able to deal with
the plumber to deal with the electrician
to do all of those quote unquote normal
things of daily life is very very hard
and I'm just hang on one second let's
realize I've started this up again and
that's not necessarily such a good thing
you're gonna have to live with this
because what happens is is that survive
you know you and I expect to survive
tonight we're going to go home we'll
wake up in the morning we expect to
survive the following day when survival
is taken for granted it no longer has a
kind of real quality to it it's just
something we assume when you are
surviving on an hour-to-hour basis or a
minute-to-minute basis it becomes a
quality which is so much more the only
way I can really think that it's like
Jeeves a crystal quality it becomes so
much more intense so much more real
it's what Katherine Leroy was talking
about she said you you feel alive like
you've never been felt alive before I'm
Christopher Maurice himself said
sometimes he would just weep to shake
the hand of the doorman at the hotel or
to turn a doorknob just the mere fact
that he was still alive was such an
incredible sense to him and so he does
bring you into a really close contact
with the reality of survival that lady
there
you may excuse me you mentioned using
the the photographs in the former you
saw in Yugoslavia for trials and I was
wondering how you felt about them trying
to force journalists and photographers
to actually testify and if that would
affect your job while you're
photographing none of the photographer's
I've spoken to none of the
photographer's I know have been forced
to testify the work that they've offered
the work that they have presented to
whether it's the international war
crimes tribunal whatever has not been
forcibly put upon them but it's a good
question because even though as I said
these are not dispassionate photographs
these are not necessarily objective
photographs they are still journalists
and of course the problem is that you
have to maintain a credibility as a
journalist in order to be able to be
allowed into the next area the next
place but I think that a certainly it to
my experience into my knowledge it's not
something that you're forced to do this
woman you mentioned there political
aspirations or motivations working with
the recipients of your Fatah like your
photographs have you ever had a body of
work that's been suppressed or how much
critical control do you have in the
photographs are actually published well
one of the things that I think is
interesting is that there are two forms
of censorship
there's censorship without censorship
within certainly during the first Gulf
War there was a huge level of censorship
and that was imposed by the military
authorities there was also in many ways
an equally high level of censorship that
was imposed by the press themselves in
the book there is a picture which is
absolutely a horrible picture of a child
Araki soldier who was in a convoy that
was going from retreating from Kuwait
back into Iraq and he has been sin dirt
by
and air power that photograph was pulled
off the wire by the AAP because it was
determined that the American public was
not able to look at images like that
it's barely been published in this
country it was published quite a lot in
Europe because there is I think no doubt
that because of the history of Europe
and the the difference just both
geographically the the fact that
everyone who lives very close to each
other each country's is butted up
against each other because they've been
so many Wars there is a kind of much
higher level of tolerance one of the
things that I find quite interesting is
that you know you talk about these these
violent images and you know the reviews
that have had at the book they often say
these are brutal images these are
horrifying images and indeed some of
them are there's no doubt about that but
we as a society can live with an
unbelievably high level of violence in
fantasy but we can't do it in reality I
mean if you look at Private Ryan Saving
Private Ryan remember that movie I have
never ever in all the time that I've
been a photographer and all the time
I've been picture editor I have never
seen photographs that were as graphic as
the images that you saw in those
pictures of the d-day d-day landing you
know the guy walking around with his arm
I'm sure that actually happened I'm sure
that that's true that was a successful
film people paid their bucks they went
to see it I suspect if that had been a
real war a real they were said no no the
American public's not ready for this
just look at the video games that our
children play those are often much more
violent than any of the pictures that
I've got in that book yes is related to
that question I'm curious what the
editorial decisions and you know even
the distribution decisions of the the
pictures that these photographers are
sending back what they are how you know
as your experience
as an editor how you can go about making
the decisions of which photographs to
put in these newspapers and how those
photographs are placed and you know did
you address the decisions about what
you're sending back very difficult to
make one of the things that it's really
really hard to try and make complex
ethical decisions when somebody's
shooting at you is not an easy job let
me tell you I remember being in Salvador
once and we were driving around and we
came across a bus that had clearly been
probably raided by the by one of the
rebel groups and beside the bus was the
body of a man he'd been executed
they put a pistol in his head and they
shot and what happens if you do that you
blow the back of the brain out and I'm
photographing this and there's always a
line between information reporting and
voyeurism and a much more dark aspect
but I'm shooting pictures and I'm
shooting and shooting and I'm going
around what photographers do they cover
every angle literally and as I come
round I'm photographing and I suddenly
realize that this voice behind me from
another photographer said Peter who the
hell do you think is going to look at
those pictures and I realize I'm
photographing the empty skull of this
guy I mean within context and that
nobody is going to look at those
pictures neither should they the
photograph that I took we showed his
empty skull was no more informative did
not give any more information to the
person who were going to look at the
picture then one I took from the front
side where you see his body beside the
bus and in the in book that picture you
know that the little kids in their snow
suits who were killed in Sarajevo I saw
the whole take and believe me some of
them were just horrific beyond belief to
me there wasn't any reason to put those
in the book the one that we chose was
perfectly adequate to do the job that
you wanted it to do
which is to move people to sympathy
which is to really say is this right is
this right that children playing in the
snow should end up in the mall and so it
was just as effective in fact actually
it was more effective because it wasn't
repellent it wasn't something that would
people would shy away from and in fact I
think in many ways the power of that
photograph is from the fact that you're
not quite sure exactly what's happening
but when you combine it with the story
which in this context is you know a
powerful combination it has a greater
degree of penetration and it does not
repel you but it brings you in at the
very back there wait we're gonna have to
get that microphone well I'm glad you
went jogging this morning at the
beginning you said that photography
offers irrefutable evidence but do you
think this is changing as digital
editing as photos can get manipulated as
powerful software exists on every
computer to change photos and for
example the I'm thinking of the two
videos of Saddam Hussein and people are
questioning what is reality right well
listen you know I don't if you ever saw
it there was a some film which was
released during the Second World War of
Hitler dancing I think it was on
Napoleon's grave when he and when he
when they took Paris and I think it was
Napoleon's grave and he chose him
dancing on Napoleon's grave he wasn't
dancing on a podiums grave at all they'd
looped it so that it looked like he was
dancing in Napoleon's grave this is
something that has happened from time
immemorial and ever since the beginning
of photography there's been some way of
manipulating it you can do it easier now
you can do it more effectively more
seamlessly there are still ways if you
really really really want to dig into it
and really analyze it where you can see
that there was manipulation so the
answer is yes
the answer is it's always been there
the answer is also that you know
journalists do triangulation they they
get evidence from several sides how do
you know when you read a story that is
an accurate story how do you know I mean
we know there have been examples where
stories in fact which of one major
awards turn out to be fabricated the way
you know is you triangulate it you go
okay he said this happened let's see
what exactly happened and one of the
interesting things in the book is that
there are several of the historical
photographs have been accused of being
fakes and one of the most famous was
taken by Robert Capa and it shows a
Spanish militiamen in Spanish Civil War
at the point of death and because of a
whole bizarre series of coincidences
people said a lot of historians said
this is a fake when the pictures
appeared in vu magazine in Paris there
were no captions they couldn't find the
negatives there were no contact sheets
and so everyone said it's a fake kappa
set it up in fact actually kappes
biographer Keuchel richard Whelan and
two former Guardsmen set out and they
actually through this amazing detective
work discovered exactly who the
Guardsman was where he was killed he was
actually the only casualty of a very
small action in Sarah Mariano which an
area in northern Spain and so you know
you can do it is that there are ways of
authenticating things and just because
you can manipulate something does that
mean say you shouldn't go out there and
shoot those pictures you shouldn't offer
them as evidence I don't think so
there's several gentlemen there you
could tell you don't even have to move
too far regarding one of the pictures on
the cover the leaves your lead picture
and your display I'm curious this guy
you said they had about 30 years
experience and I'm curious about his
clothing
it's just Street clothing he's wearing a
white shirt is Street shoes I once was
in gym knock Ray's apartment and out of
curiosity I opened a closet he has
probably 40 identical outfits to that
you never see him in anything anything
about a minutes
he's has always done he's just that he
was also in you know there's a
difference between when you're in an
area where you do go to a hotel instead
you know like I said every almost every
conflict as a hotel which is associated
with it for me it was the Europa Hotel
in Belfast and the communion rail in San
Salvador here he was on the West Bank
and you can go back to you know your
hotel at night and you can get your
laundry done and you can change your
clothes
however Jim nitrate also was on the run
for several weeks from the Sri Lankan
army because he had been with the rebels
who were operating in the northern part
of Sri Lanka and he literally had to
hide out wherever he could trust me he
didn't look that good after those two or
three weeks that he was on the run so
that's the that's the answer to that he
he looked good and he looked cleanly
dressed because he could because he was
going back to the hotel that night
pardon me but my question is don't isn't
there any compulsion to protect yourself
with more clothing oh I'm sorry I told
you my hearings you know way gone yeah
sure I mean you know people do we're
we're certainly there are all of them
are wearing chem so I have chem suits
with them
I had actually lunch with two of them
before they went off to the Middle East
one Jim is a contract photographer for
Time the other one Ron Aviv is a
contract that over for Newsweek and the
topic of conversation was you know what
kind of Kim sook did they get you you
know and so they also wear bulletproof
vests sometimes the disadvantage of
bulletproof vests particularly if it's
hot I actually used to wear one in
Salvador but a lot of people didn't
because it
get really really hard the other thing
is that this book is dedicated to a very
close friend of mine who was killed in
El Salvador bulletproof vests have weak
points and one of the weak points is
under the arms where the two panels come
together he was shot in exactly that
place the problem when that happens
which is a problem in itself any right
but when that happens you're wearing a
bulletproof vest there is no exit wound
the bullet tumbles around inside your
body because you can't get out because
the bulletproof vest
instead of protecting you from the
bullet coming in is not allowing the
bullet to go out so a lot of people
won't use bulletproof vests at all and
so you know that's probably what Jim
doesn't have the bulletproof vest right
that gentleman there where in the world
is the most I hate to say voracious
audience but I guess that's what I mean
why and especially because they cannot
understand what they see since they have
not been in war I don't quite understand
the question did you say we are the most
voracious no where in the world that is
the most voracious audience for these
pictures and why are they so interested
especially because they cannot
understand what it is like to be in
temperature kill yeah I think it varies
from from conflict conflict people are
always much more interested in conflicts
that affect them in some way whatever
you know one of the biggest shocks I
think for Europe with the dreadful
conflict in in the former Yugoslavia was
its Europe that was a part of Europe it
wasn't a part of North America it wasn't
a part of our interests I think our
interest in that particular conflict was
way less than the interest of Europeans
so I think that it really depends on
what the conflict is and what where your
interests are you know where your
involvement is I do however think I'll
go back to what I said before I think
that there is
a higher level of understanding of war
and the realities of war in Europe
because of the history of that continent
then there is here and God knows maybe
that's something that is pretty good I
mean if what it means is is that we as a
nation have not been inflicted upon
those kind of things apart from of
course the civil war and I think one of
the most interesting statistics out of
the civil war is that the casualties the
number of casualties in the Civil War is
greater than all of the casualties of
every war that America has been involved
in put together since that time and that
was the degree of catastrophe that the
Civil War was and that affected our
nation for a very very long time at the
very back from the you know for the
recent 20th century in the 21st century
regarding media access to war fronts you
know you know you have you seen a
difference in the marketing of of your
product and you know maybe from war to
you might have had a few few photograph
furs working for a few major papers than
Vietnam a few more and you had more and
more production deadlines I mean maybe
one big photo month per month
Vietnam maybe one per week now you know
they're rolling with cameras as they
drive down the street and so is it is
does that affect the product or your
survivability or I think that what it's
affected well I think that actually
television coverage and particularly
cable television coverage and you know
as we saw from CNN in the first war and
as we're now seeing has really affected
it dramatically still photographs having
a harder and harder time to break
through the noise of the coverage of the
television bigger because you know there
is this need it seems to have something
on a television screen almost 24 hours a
day much of it's very boring
I am already really fed up by looking at
the skyline of Baghdad you know it's not
but there's nothing left to show and
they have to show a visual and as a
result of that photographs still
photographs which have significance and
which will we hope survival and live are
having a at least initially at least as
we as we see this war unfold before us
they usually at they're having a harder
time to find an audience in the market
you know the big picture magazines are
gone life's gone looks gone and so it is
much more difficult together however I
still fundamentally and firmly believe
that the human brain can memorize and be
affected by still image much more than a
moving image there are several examples
of this associated with war photography
where you've had a something which has
been photographed and either filmed or
videotaped at the same time the raising
of the flag at Iwo Jima was video was
filmed by a Defense Department cameraman
the MacArthur wading ashore of the
Philippines was also filmed the street
execution by the the police general in
in Saigon that also was was was filmed
we don't remember the the film because
the mind can't hold on to a succession
of images we need to have an the
encapsulation that still photography
gives in order to do to retain it and
these have become icons so you become
you know a part of our collective
cultural consciousness and it is because
they have that ability to really really
burn themselves into our memory and I
think that that's still as true now as
it always has been this gentleman here
do any of these photographers use their
photographic skills artistically to
create works that are a balance
to the horrific images that they do
while they're working do they do
landscape or still life there as well as
I said da McCullen only shoes landscape
now he lives in a particularly beautiful
part of England in the place called
Somerset and he spends his life
photographing landscapes around his
house and and in other locations and
also a lot in Africa he's been doing a
lot of landscapes in Africa
Jim nachtweh doesn't necessarily
photograph other things but when he
comes back from a war zone and he loves
to go and fly fish that's his way of
being over to just take drain the brain
just wash the the memories at least
temporarily out of his brain so I think
each of them deal with it in a different
way and for some it is to photograph
other things but I think that there is a
compunction to doing these kind of
images which doesn't exist in in other
areas for a lot of the reasons that
we've already discussed you're gonna
have to move to that one one of the back
there and then we take you in conflicts
where you're viewed as a threat to the
particular government which sort of
implications are there for the people
that you may have interaction with I'm
sorry sorry that again in particular
conflicts where you as a journalist or
viewed as a threat to the government
yeah what sort of implications are there
for the public with whom you may have
interactions oh I see what you mean
again that varies widely and a lot of
the people that are photographed in this
book are already victims at the time
that they're being photographed so you
know the possible consequences are being
photographed pretty minimal if you're
about to be executed
what worst thing can happen to you
but I certainly think that there are a
number of there are a number of issues
that the photographer has to take into
account when they're working the problem
is it's like I was saying you know it's
so hard to make these complex ethical
issues to make these complex ethical
decisions when you're being shot at it
is not easy to make those decisions I
think that that is really the role of
the editor of the editor certainly
wouldn't be able to prevent any
consequences coming out of it for for
those people in the photograph I don't
think that it's something which happens
a lot within the particular battle but
when you're say you're in El Salvador
and you're interacting with just people
on the streets are there any
implications for their safety or their
well-being once you leave as a
journalist I guess it depends upon what
what you're doing what they're doing it
depends upon what the situation is it's
not something you can I don't know that
you can really decide that when you're
working I'm not sure that you can really
know exactly what the but you do I think
more importantly know when I said the
way that photographers are being
manipulated one of the things that
Patrick Chapelle says you know
particularly in the ethnic cleansing of
the former Yugoslavia sir paramilitary
units would go into an into a village
they would kill everyone in the village
bury them in a shallow grave
that action became much more effective
from their point of view if it was seen
because all of the people in the other
villages would see what the consequences
were so that is the kind of manipulation
which hack can happen and which is very
very difficult to to counteract and to
not be a part of and something they're
very aware of the gentleman in front
there I'm also interested in that first
image of the several photographers
crouching under fire I noticed there's a
few images where there's a few
photographers at the same place now how
is it in a warzone that for one that can
become friends and spend time together
in this
attic atmosphere how often are they
actually shooting together in the same
zone were they I mean it's the exact
opposite of what your own lists doing
every you know the ideal for journalists
is to be the only person there and
before everyone else did the young
photographers tend to maybe or is there
any certain group of photographers or
single divers who tend to go out on
their own trying to find the freshest
more more adventurous with Morgan yeah
one of the things you know actually that
one of the things that I always say when
if I'm doing I've been doing lectures at
universities and things and people will
come up to me and say I really want to
be a combat photographer and my advice
if they said what's your advice and my
advice my initial advice is don't my
secondary advice if that doesn't work is
be absolutely sure why you're doing it
if you are doing it to make a name for
yourself do not do it if you're doing it
because you really have a real deep
feeling that this is important work and
you should be doing it do it but if you
go into your first war situation do
exactly what the veterans do follow them
exactly do not vary your movement one
iota from what they're doing until you
get to the point you have enough
experience to know and they say I think
a terrific example of that in the book
it's a picture that Philip Jones
Griffith shot in in Vietnam he and a
group of GIS were in a what was probably
an old French bread truck it was a sort
of Citroen truck and they're driving
along and they come under Vietcong
machine-gun fire
first of all Philip were sitting not in
the truck but with these legs dangling
over the back of the truck so he was off
that truck like that he was off before
the soldiers were the soldiers ran to
the left so he ran to the right because
he knew the Vietcong were much more
likely to be shooting at the soldiers
and they were at him Plus also he got
some very dramatic photographs one of
which is in the book of these guys
running from from the from the van
a less experienced photographer would
have gone with the soldiers and might
very well have been killed so that is
the difference that experience makes in
these instances way down here
it's curious in situations where the
photographers can barely get in and out
themselves how they get their film out
to get it sent back to New York and
places like that of it well nowadays
it's actually a lot easier because we've
you got a digital camera a laptop
computer and a Sat phone you can just
transmit directly from where you are
that's one of the fears of the the
military authorities is I mean literally
you can transmit photographs back to
your news desk while the battles
happening and clearly that's why they're
they're imposing you know blackout
periods which you know absolutely a
sensible thing to do but if you're
shooting film it's very much harder and
sometimes the film only comes out when
you come out in Sarajevo there were UN
flights that went in and out every day
the film could come out on the uran
flight the photographers came in and out
on the UM flight so that was the way
their that got out even though it's a
lot easier nowadays because of all this
technology one of the problems is now
photographers biggest concern is
electricity because they've got to keep
the batteries charged and the laptop the
batteries charged in the satphone and
the batteries charged in their cameras
and there was a situation in Afghanistan
which I thought was a wonderful
convergence of the the new and the old
was that several photographers had
generators in gasoline shipped across
the mountains on horseback so that which
they've needed in order to be able to do
the most modern technology